los ciudadanos que son seguidores de
bolsonaron el país y que no están de
acuerdo con el resultado de la elección
han hecho convocatorias a lo largo de
Brasil frente a los comandos militares
para mostrar en su inconformidad con el
resultado de como presidente a partir
del primero de enero y para pedir lo que
ellos llaman una intervención federal
vamos a hablar sobre lo que es esa
intervención federal y para ello me
acompaña precisamente uno de los
activistas
he estado aquí Hoy estamos aquí
nosotros estamos aquí porque el pueblo
percibió una interferencia de los
poderes principalmente judicial e
interferencia en relación con la
estructura del país actualmente el
pueblo no está haciendo más esto de
quedarse esperando le voy a contar una
cosa estamos aquí porque esta elección
no fue transparente fue un activismo
judicial muy grande el que hicieron los
poderes
esa intervención Federal es que los
militares restablezcan el orden popular
y el equilibrio de fuerzas en relación a
los poderes lo fuimos a decir en las
urnas y el pueblo está viendo eso el
actual presidente tiene el apoyo popular
y él que fue elegido no lo tiene
nosotros vemos que fue la prensa Y
tenemos esas informaciones mire aquí a
la vuelta tiene mucha gente y no tiene
como decir que bolsonaro no tiene apoyo
y no queremos ser gobernados por un
corrupto condenado que salió por un
malabarismo judicial para gobernar el
país
entonces lo que dicen aquí los
ciudadanos que están en contra de la
elección del huracán Silva es que están
buscando una mano amiga en el ejército
para contestar esta elección que apenas
fue ganada por poco más de 12 millones
de votos Así que lo que vemos es un país
que está completamente polarizado y que
después de un discurso de evolucionario
en el que él no habló directamente de
Lula de Silva ni aceptó directamente el
resultado
creo que avanzara el proceso de
transición pues lo que vemos es que hay
mucho ya por decir sobre esta elección y
veremos pues como siguen los
pronunciamientos de la ciudadanía además
se recordemos que hay bloqueos de
camioneros todavía en varias desde las
vías principales